[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHRIS KELLEY: Thank you
so much for joining us.
My name is Chris.
I'm a designer and
prototyper working
on immersive
prototyping at Google,
and I'm joined by
Ellie and Luca.
And today, we're going to talk
about exploring AR interaction.
It's really awesome to be here.
We explore immersive computing
through rapid prototyping
of AR and VR experiments.
Often, that's focused on use
case exploration or app ideas.
We work fast, which
means we fail fast,
but that means
that we learn fast.
We spend a week or two on
each prototyping sprint,
and at the end of
the sprint, we end
with a functional
prototype starting
from a tightly scoped question.
And then we put that
prototype in people's hands
and we see what we can learn.
So this talk is going to
be about takeaways we have
from those AR explorations.
But first, I want to set
the table a little bit
and talk about what we mean
when we say augmented reality.
When a lot of people
think about AR,
the first thing they think about
is bringing virtual objects
to users in the world.
And it is that.
That's part of it.
We call this the out of AR.
But AR also means
more than that.
It means being able to
understand the world visually
to bring information to users,
and we call this understanding
the in of AR.
Many of the tools
and techniques that
were created for computer vision
and machine learning perfectly
complement tools like
ARCore, which is Google's AR
development platform.
So when we explore AR,
we build experiences
that include one of
these approaches or both.
So this talk is going to
be about three magic powers
that we've found for AR.
We think that these magic powers
can help you build better AR
experiences for your users.
So we're going to talk about
some prototypes that we've
built and share our
learnings with you
during each of these three magic
power areas during the talk.
First, I'll talk to you about
context-driven superpowers.
That's about how we can
combine visual and physical
understanding of the world to
make magical AR experiences.
Then Ellie will talk to you
about shared augmentations.
And this is really all
about the different ways
that we can connect
people together in AR,
and how we can empower them
just by putting them together.
And then Luca will
cover expressive inputs.
This is about how
AR can help unlock
authentic and natural
understanding for our users.
So let's start about
context-driven superpowers.
What this really means
is using AR technologies
to deeply understand
the context of a device,
and then build experiences that
directly leverage that context.
And there's two parts
to an AR context.
One is visual
understanding, and the other
is physical understanding.
With ARCore, this
gives your phone
the ability to
understand and sense
its environment physically.
But through computer vision
and machine learning,
we can make sense of
the world visually.
And by combining
these results, we
get an authentic
understanding of the scene,
which is a natural building
block of magical AR.
So let's start with
visual understanding.
The prototyping community has
done some awesome explorations
here, and we've done
a few of our own
that we're excited to share.
To start, we
wondered if we could
trigger custom experiences from
visual signals in the world.
Traditional apps today
leverage all kinds of device
signals to trigger experiences.
GPS, the IMU, et cetera.
So could we use visual
input as a signal as well?
We built a really basic
implementation of this concept.
This uses ARCore and
the Google Cloud Vision
API that detects
any kind of snowman
in the scene, which triggers
a particle system that
starts to snow.
So through visual
understanding, we
were able to tailor an
experience to specific cues
in the environment for users.
This enables adaptable and
context aware applications.
So even though this
example is a simple one,
the concept can be
extended so much further.
For example, yesterday we
announced the augmented images
API for ARCore.
So if you use this,
you can make something
like an experience that reacts
relative to device movement
around an image in
the scene, or even
from a known distance to
an object in the world.
If you think this
concept is interesting,
I highly recommend checking
out the AR VR demo tent.
They have some amazing
augmented images demos there.
The next thing we
wanted to know is
if we could bridge the gap
between digital and physical,
and, for example, bring some
of the most delightful features
of e-readers to physical books.
The digital age has brought
all kinds of improvements
to some traditional
human behaviors,
and e-readers have brought lots
of cool new things to reading.
But if you're like
me, sometimes you just
missed the tactility in holding
a great book in your hands.
So we wanted to know if
we could bridge that gap.
In this prototype, users
highlight a passage or word
with their finger
and they instantly
get back a definition.
This is a great example of a
short-form-focused interaction
that required no
setup for users.
It was an easy win
only made possible
by visual understanding.
But as soon as we
tried this prototype,
there were two downfalls
that we noticed,
and they became immediately
apparent when we used it.
The first is that it was really
difficult to aim your finger
at a small moving
target on a phone,
and maybe the page
is moving as well,
and you're trying to
target this little word.
That was really hard.
And the second was that when
you're highlighting a word,
your finger is blocking
the exact thing
that you're trying to see.
Now, these are easily solvable
with a follow-up UX iteration,
but they illustrate
a larger lesson.
And that's that with any
kind of immersive computing,
you really have to try it
before you can judge it.
An interaction might sound
great when you talk about it
and it might even look
good in a visual mock,
but until you have
it in your hand
and you can feel it
and try it, you're
not going to know
if it works or not.
You really have to
put it in a prototype
so you can create
your own facts.
Another thing we
think about a lot
is, can we help people
learn more effectively?
Could we use AR to
make learning better?
There's many styles of
learning, and if you
combine these
styles of learning,
it often results in faster
and higher-quality learning.
In this prototype, we
combined visual, oral, verbal,
and kinesthetic learning
to teach people how
to make the perfect espresso.
The videos explain--
I'm sorry.
We placed videos around
the espresso machine
in the physical locations
where that step occurs.
So if you were learning
how to use the grinder,
the video for the grinder
is right next to it.
Now, for users to
trigger that video,
they move their
phone to the area
and then they can
watch the lesson.
That added physical component
of the physical proximity
of the video and
the actual device
made a huge difference
in general understanding.
In our studies, users who had
never used an espresso machine
before easily made an espresso
after using this prototype.
So for some kinds
of learning, this
can be really
beneficial for users.
Now, unfortunately
for our prototype,
one thing that we
learned here was
that it's actually really
hard to hold your phone
and make an espresso
at the same time.
So you need to be really
mindful of the fact
that your users
might be splitting
their physical resources
between the phone and the world.
And so as it applies
to your use case,
try building experiences
that are really
snackable and hands-free.
Speaking of combining learning
and superpowers together,
we wondered if AR
could help us learn
from hidden information
that's layered in the world
all around us.
This is a prototype
that we built
that's an immersive
language learning app.
We showed translations roughly
next to objects of interest
and positioned these labels
by taking a point cloud
sample from around the object
and putting the label sort
of in the middle of the points.
Users found this kind of
immersive learning really fun,
and we saw users
freely exploring
the world looking for other
things to learn about.
So we found that
if you give people
the freedom to roam and tools
that are simple and flexible,
the experiences that
you build for them
can create immense value.
We now have physical
understanding.
This is AR's ability
to extract and infer
information and meaning
from the world around you.
When a device knows exactly
where it is, not only in space,
but also relative
to other devices,
we can start to do
things that really
feel like you have superpowers.
For example, we
can start to make
interactions that are
extremely physical, natural,
and delightful.
Humans have been
physically interacting
with each other for
a really long time,
but digital life has abstracted
some of those interactions.
We wondered if we could
swing the pendulum
back the other direction
a little bit using AR.
So in this prototype, much like
a carnival milk bottle game,
you fling a baseball out
of the top of your phone
and it hits milk bottles that
are shown on other devices.
You just point the ball where
you want to go, and it goes.
We did this by putting
multiple devices
in a shared coordinate
system, which
you could do using the new
Google Cloud Anchors API
that we announced
for ARCore yesterday.
And one thing you'll
notice here is
that we aren't even showing
users past their camera.
Now, we did that deliberately
because we really
wanted to stretch
and see how far we
could take this concept
of physical interaction.
And one thing we learned
was that once people learned
to do it, they found
it really natural
and actually had a
lot of fun with it.
But almost every user that
tried it had to be not only
told how to do it, but
shown how to do it.
People actually had to
flip this mental switch
of the expectations they
have for how a 2D smartphone
interaction works.
So you really need to be mindful
of the context that people
are bringing in and the
mental models they have
for 2D smartphone interactions.
We also wanted to know if we
could help someone visualize
the future in a way that would
let them make better decisions.
Humans pay attention to the
things that matter to us.
And in a literal
sense, the imagery
that appears in our
peripheral vision
takes a lower cognitive
priority than the things
we're focused on.
Would smartphone AR
be any different?
In this experiment, we
overlaid the architectural mesh
of the homeowner's remodel on
top of the active construction
project.
The homeowner could
visualize in context
what the changes to their
home was going to look like.
Now, at the time that this
prototype was created,
we had to do actual manual
alignment of this model
on top of the house.
You could do it today.
If I rebuilt it, I would
use the augmented images API
that we announced yesterday.
It would be much
easier to put a fixed
image in a location, the
house, and sync them together.
But even with that initial
friction for the UX,
the homeowner got tremendous
value out of this.
In fact, they went back to their
architect after seeing this
and changed the design
of their new home
because they found out
that they weren't going
to have enough space in the
upstairs bathroom-- something
they hadn't noticed
in the plans before.
So the lesson is that if you
provide people high-quality,
personally relevant
content, you can create ways
that people will find really
valuable and attention grabbing
experiences.
But when does modifying
the real environment
start to break down?
You may be familiar
with the uncanny valley.
It's a concept
that suggests when
things that are really
familiar to humans
are almost right but
just a little bit off,
it makes us feel uneasy.
Subtle manipulations of
the real environment in AR
can sometimes feel similar.
It can be difficult
to get right.
In this specific
example, we tried
removing things from the world.
We created this AR invisibility
cloak for the plant.
What we did was we created a
point cloud around the object,
attached little cubes
to the point cloud,
applied a material
to those points,
and extracted the texture from
the surrounding environment.
That worked pretty well
in uniform environments,
but unfortunately, the world
doesn't have too many of those.
It's made up of dynamic
lighting and subtle patterns,
so this always ended up
looking a little bit weird.
Remember to be thoughtful
about the way that you add
or remove things
from the environment.
People are really
perceptive, and so you
need to strive to
build experiences
that align with
their expectations,
or at the very least,
don't defy them.
But is physical understanding
always critical?
All points in the
section have their place,
but, ultimately, you have to
be guided by your critical user
journeys.
In this example,
we wanted to build
a viewer for this amazing 3D
model by Damon [INAUDIBLE]..
It was important that people
could see the model in 3D
and move around to
discover the object.
A challenge, though,
was that the camera feed
was creating a lot of visual
noise and distraction.
People were having a
hard time appreciating
the nuances of the model.
We adopted concepts from
filmmaking and guided users
by using focus and
depth of field,
all which were controlled
by the user's motion.
This resulted in people
feeling encouraged to explore,
and they really stopped
getting distracted
by the physical environment.
So humans are already
great at so many things.
AR really allows us to leverage
those existing capabilities
to make interactions
feel invisible.
If we leverage visual and
physical understanding
together, we can
build experiences that
really give people superpowers.
With that, Ellie is
going to talk to you
about special opportunities we
have in shared augmentations.
ELLIE NATTINGER: Thanks, Chris.
So I'm Ellie Nattinger.
I'm a software
engineer and prototyper
on Google's VR and AR team.
Chris has talked about
the kinds of experiences
you start to have when
your devices can understand
the world around
you, and I'm going
to talk about what happens when
you can share those experiences
with the people around you.
We're interested not only
in adding AR augmentations
to your own reality, but also
in sharing those augmentations.
If you listened to the
developer keynote yesterday,
you know that shared
AR experiences
is a really big topic
for us these days.
For one thing, a
shared reality lets
people be immersed in
the same experience.
Think about a movie theater.
Why do movie theaters exist?
Everybody's watching a movie
that they could probably
watch at home on their
television or their computer
by themselves much
more comfortably not
having to go anywhere,
but it feels qualitatively
different to be in a space
with other people sharing
that experience.
And beyond those kinds of
shared passive experiences,
having a shared reality lets
you collaborate, lets you learn,
lets you build
and play together.
We think you should be able to
share your augmented realities
with your friends, and your
families, and your colleagues,
so we've done a
variety of explorations
about how do you build
those kinds of shared
realities in AR.
First, there's kind of
a technical question.
How do you get people
aligned in a shared AR space?
There's a number of
ways we've tried.
If you don't need
a lot of accuracy,
you could just start your
apps with all the devices
in approximately
the same location.
You could use markers
or augmented images
so multiple users can all point
their devices at one picture
and get a common
point of reference--
cures the zero, zero,
zero of my virtual world.
And you can even use the
new ARCore Cloud Anchors API
that we just announced
yesterday to localize
multiple devices against
the visual features
of a particular space.
In addition to the
technical considerations,
we've found three
axes of experience
that we think are really
useful to consider
when you're designing
these kinds of shared
augmented experiences.
First of those is
co-located versus remote.
Are your users in the
same physical space
or different physical spaces?
Second is, how much precision
is required, or is it optional?
Do you have to have everybody
see the virtual bunny
at exactly the same
point in the world,
or do you have a little bit
of flexibility about that?
And the third is
whether your experience
is synchronous or asynchronous.
Is everybody participating
in this augmented experience
at exactly the same time, or
at slightly different times?
And we see these not as
necessarily binary axes,
but more of a
continuum that you can
consider when you're designing
these multi-person AR
experiences.
So let's talk about some
prototypes and apps that
fall on different points of
the spectrum and the lessons
we've learned from them.
To start with, we've
found that when
you've got a group
that's interacting
with the same content
in the same space,
you really need shared,
precise, spatial registration.
For example, let's say
you're in a classroom.
Imagine if a group
of students who
are doing a unit on the solar
system could all look at
and walk around the globe,
or an asteroid field,
or look at the sun.
In Expeditions AR, one
of Google's initial AR
experiences, all the students
can point their devices
to a marker, they
calibrate themselves
against a shared location,
they see the object
in the same place, and
then what this allows
is for a teacher to
be able to point out
particular parts of the object.
Oh, if you all come over and
look at this side of the sun,
you see a cut-out into its core.
Over here on the Earth,
you can see a hurricane.
Everybody starts get a
spatial understanding
of the parts of the object and
where they are in the world.
So when does it matter
that your shared
space has a lot of precision?
When you have
multiple people who
are all in the
same physical space
interacting with or
looking at the exact same
augmented objects
at the same time.
We were also curious--
how much can we take advantage
of people's existing spatial
awareness when you're working
in high-precision shared spaces?
We experimented with this in
this multi-person construction
application, where you've
got multiple people who
are all building onto a shared
AR object in the same space.
Adding blocks to each
other, everybody's
being able to coordinate.
And you want to be able to tell
what part of the object someone
is working on.
Have your physical movement
support that collaboration.
Like, if Chris is
over here and he's
placing some green
blocks in the real world,
I'm not going to
step in front of him
and start putting yellow
blocks there instead.
We've got a natural sense of how
to collaborate, how to arrange,
how to coordinate
ourselves in space.
People already have that sense.
So we can keep
that in a shared AR
if we've got our virtual objects
precisely lined up enough.
We also found it
helpful to notice
that because you can see both
the digital object but also
the other people through
the pass-through camera,
you are able to get a pretty
good sense of what people
were looking at as well as what
they were interacting with.
We've also wondered
what would it
feel like to have a shared AR
experience for multiple people
in the same space, but who
aren't necessarily interacting
with the same things?
So think of this more
like an AR LAN party.
Where we're all
in the same space,
or maybe could be
different spaces,
we're seeing connected
things, and we're
having a shared experience.
So this prototype's a
competitive quiz guessing game
where you look at
the map and you
have to figure out where on the
globe you think is represented
and stick your
pushpin in, get points
depending on how close you are.
We've got the state synced,
so we know who's winning.
But the location of
where that globe is
doesn't actually need
to be synchronized.
And maybe you don't want it to
be synchronized because I don't
want anybody to get a clue
based on where I'm sticking
my pushpin into the globe.
It's fun to be together,
even when we're not looking
at exactly the same AR things.
And do we always need our
spaces to align exactly?
Sometimes it's enough just
to be in the same room.
This prototype example's
of an AR boat race.
You blow on the
microphone of your phone,
and it creates the wind
that propels your boat
down the little AR track.
By us being next to each
other when we start the app
and spawn the track, we get
a shared physical experience
even though our AR worlds
might not perfectly align.
We get to keep all the elements
of the social game play--
talking to each other,
our physical presence--
but we're not necessarily
touching the same objects.
Another super interesting
area we've been playing with
is how audio can
be a way to include
multiple people in a single
device AR experience.
If you think of the standard
Magic Window device AR,
it's a pretty
personal experience.
I'm looking at this
thing through my phone.
But now, imagine you can
leave a sound in AR that
has a 3D position like
any other virtual thing,
and now you start to
be able to hear it,
even if you're not
necessarily looking at it.
And other people
can hear the sound
from your device
at the same time.
So for an example, let's say
you could leave little notes
all over your space.
Might look something like this.
I'm a plant.
I'm elephant.
This is a chair.
I'm a plant.
I'm elephant.
This is a chair.
So notice, you don't have
to be the one with a phone
to get a sense of where
these audio annotations start
to live in physical space.
Another question we've asked--
if you have a synchronous AR
experience with multiple people
who are in different places,
what kind of representation
do you need of the other person?
So let's imagine you have
maybe a shared AR photos app
where multiple people
can look at photos
that are arranged in space.
So I'm taking pictures
in one location,
I'm viewing them
arranged around me in AR,
and then I want to
share my AR experience
with Luca, who comes
in and joins me
from a remote location.
What we found-- we needed
a couple of things to make
us feel like we were connected
and sharing the same AR
experience, even though we
were in different places.
We needed to have a voice
connection so we could actually
talk about the
pictures, and we needed
to know where the other
person was looking.
See which picture you're
paying attention to when
you're talking about it.
But what was interesting
is we didn't actually
need to know where the other
person was, as long as we had
that shared frame of reference.
We're all here, here's
what I'm looking at,
here's what Luca's looking at.
We've also been curious
about asymmetric experiences.
What happens when users
share the same space
and the same augmentations,
but they've got different roles
in the experience?
So for instance,
in this prototype,
Chris is using his phone as a
controller to draw in space,
but he's not actually seeing
the AR annotations he's drawing.
The other person sees
the same AR content
and uses their phone
to take a video.
They're playing different
roles in the same experience.
Kind of artist versus
cinematographer.
And we found there
could be some challenges
to asymmetric
experiences if there's
a lack of information about
what the other person is
experiencing.
For instance, Chris can't
tell what Luca's filming
or see how his drawing
looks from far away.
So as we mentioned
previously, these kinds
of different
combinations of space,
and time, and precision are
relevant for multi-person AR
experiences, and they have
different technical and
experiential needs.
If you have multiple
people in the same space
with the same augmentations
at the same time,
then you need a way of sharing.
You need a way of
common localization.
That's why we created the
new Cloud Anchors API.
If you've got multiple
people in the same space
with different augmentations
at the same time,
the kind of AR LAN
party model, you
need some way to share data.
And if you've got
multiple people
in different spaces interacting
with the same augmentations
at the same time,
you need sharing
in some kind of representation
of that interaction.
So shared AR experiences
is a big area.
We've explored some
parts of the space.
We'd love to see what
you all come up with.
So Chris has talked
about examples
where your device
understands your surroundings
and gives you special powers,
I talked about examples
where you've got
multiple people who
can collaborate and interact.
Now Luca will talk about what
happens when your devices have
a better understanding
of you and allow
for more expressive inputs.
Luca?
LUCA PRASSO: Thank you, Ellie.
My name is Luca Prasso,
and I'm a prototyper
and a technical artist working
in the Google AR and VR team.
So let's talk about
the device that you
carry with you every day and the
ones that are all around you,
and how they can provide
the meaningful and authentic
signals that we can use in
our augmented experiences.
So ARCore tracks
the device motion
as we move to the real world
and provides some understanding
of the environment.
And these signals can be used to
create powerful, and creative,
and expressive tools,
and offer new ways for us
to interact with
digital content.
So the data represents
who we are, what we know,
and what we have.
And we were interested
in understanding
if the user can connect more
deeply if the data is displayed
around them in 3D, and through
AR and physical aspirations,
they can look at this data.
So we took a database of
several thousand world cities,
and we mapped it
in an area that's
wide as a football field.
We assign a dot to every city
and we scale the dot based
on the population of the city.
And each country has
a different color.
So now you can walk
to this data field.
And as ARCore tracks
the motion of the user,
we play footsteps in sync.
You take a step and
you hear a step.
And [INAUDIBLE] sound
fields surrounds the user
and enhances the experience
and the sense of exploration
of this data forest.
And flight paths are
displayed up in the sky.
And the pass-through
camera is heavily tinted
so that we can allow the
user to focus on the data
and then still give
a sense of presence.
And what happens is the user, as
he walks to the physical space,
he starts mapping, and
pairing, and creating
this mental map between the
data and the physical location.
And starts understanding
better, in this particular case,
the relative distance
between the places.
And what we discover is
also that the gestures that
are a part of our digital life
every day, a pinch to zoom,
it's now in AR something
more traditional.
It's actually moving closer
to the digital object
and inspecting it like
we do with a real object.
And pan and drag means
taking a couple of steps
to the right to look
at the information.
So physical exploration like
this is very fascinating,
but we need to take into
account all the different users
and provide the alternative
move and affordances.
So in AR, a user
can move everywhere,
but what if he cannot or
he doesn't want to move?
What if he's sitting?
So in this particular case, we
allow the user to simply point
the phone everywhere they
want to go, tap on the screen
anywhere, and the application
will move the point of view
in that direction.
At the same time, we still
have to provide audio, haptics,
and color effects to enhance
the sense of physical space
the user has to have
while traveling.
And so we found that this
is a powerful mechanism
to explore a certain type of
data that makes sense in the 3D
space and to allow the user
to discover hidden patterns.
But can we go beyond
the pixels that you
can find on your screen?
We're fascinated by the
spatial audio and a way
to incorporate audio
into an AR experience.
So we combine ARCore and
the Google Resonance SDK.
And Resonance is this very
powerful spatial audio engine
that recently
Google open-sourced.
And you should check it
out because it's great.
And so now I can
take audio sources
and place them into
the 3D locations,
and animate them, and describe
the properties of the walls,
and the ceilings, and the
floor, and all the obstacles.
And now as the ARCore
moves the point of view,
it carries with it
the digital ears,
the Resonance used
to render accurately
the sounds in the scene.
So what can we do with this?
So we imagine, what if I
can sit next to a performer
during an acoustic concert, or
a classical concert, or a jazz
performance?
What if I can be
onstage with actors,
and listen to their
play, and be there?
So we took two amazing
actors, Chris and Ellie,
and we asked them
to record separately
lines from Shakespeare.
And we placed these audio
sources a few feet apart
and we surrounded
the environment
with an ambisonic sound field of
a rain forest, of the raining.
And then later on, we switched
to a room with a lot of reverb
into the walls.
CHRIS KELLEY: Thou told'st
me they were stolen unto this
wood, and here I am, and
wode within this wood,
because I cannot meet my Hermia.
Hence, get thee gone,
and follow me no more.
ELLIE NATTINGER: You draw
me, you hard-hearted adamant,
but yet you draw not iron,
for my heart is true as steel.
Leave you your power
to draw, and I shall
have no power to follow you.
CHRIS KELLEY: Do I entice you?
Do I speak to you fair?
Or rather, do I not in plainest
truth tell you, I do not,
nor I cannot love you?
LUCA PRASSO: So now the
user can walk around,
maybe with his eyes closed,
a nice pair of headphones,
and it's like being on
stage with these actors.
So we took this example
and we extended it.
We observed that we can build
in real-time a 2D map of where
the user has been so
far with his phone
as he's walking around.
And so at any given time
when the user hits a button,
we can programmatically place
audio recording in space
where we know that the user
can reach with the phone
and with their ears.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
And suddenly, the user
becomes the human mixer
of this experience.
And different
instruments can populate
your squares, and your
rooms, and your schools.
And this opens the door
to an amazing amount
of opportunities with AR
audio-first experiments.
So let's go back to
visual understanding.
Chris mentioned that the
computer vision and machine
learning can interpret the
things that are around us,
and this is also important to
understand the body in turning
into an expressive controller.
So in real life,
we are surrounded
by a lot of sound sources
for all of the places.
And naturally, our
body and our head
moves to mix and
focus on what we like
and what we want to listen to.
So can we take this intuition
into the way we watch movies
or play video games
on a mobile device?
So what we did, we took
the phone camera signal,
fed it to Google Mobile Vision.
That gave us a head position
and head orientation.
And we fed it to
Google Resonance SDK.
And we said, OK, you're
watching a scene in which actors
are in a forest, and they're all
around you, and it's raining.
So now as I leave my phone
far away from my head,
I hear the forest.
As I'm taking the phone
closer to my face,
I start hearing
the actors playing.
I warn you, this is
an Oscar performance.
[THUNDER RUMBLES]
ELLIE NATTINGER:
Our company here.
CHRIS KELLEY: My man,
according to the script.
ELLIE NATTINGER: Here is the
scroll of every man's name
which is thought fit through all
Athens to play in our interlude
before the duke and the
duchess on his [INAUDIBLE]
LUCA PRASSO: So now
what is interesting is
that the tiny little
motions that we
can do when we're watching and
we're playing this experience,
it can be turned into
subtle changes in the user
experience that we can control.
So we talk about how
the changes in poses
can become a trigger
to drive interaction.
In this Google Research
app called [INAUDIBLE],,
we actually exploit
the opposite--
the absence of motion.
And when the user--
in this case, my kids--
stop posing, the
app takes a picture.
And so the simple mechanism that
is triggered by computer vision
creates the incredible,
delightful opportunities
that, apparently, my kids love.
And Research is doing
incredible progress
in looking at an RGB image
and understanding where
the body pose and skeleton is.
And you should check out the
Google Research blog post
because their post estimation
research is amazing.
So we took Ellie's video and we
fed it to the machine computer
algorithm.
And we got back, a bunch of
3D poses and segmentation
masks of Ellie.
And this opens the door
to a lot of variety
of experiments with
creative filters
that we can apply to this.
But what's more
interesting for us
is that it also allows
us to understand better
the intent and the
context of the user.
So we took this pose
estimation technology
and we added a
digital character.
Now it tries to mimic what
the human character is doing.
And this allows [INAUDIBLE]
now to bring your family
and friends--
in this case, my son, Noah--
into the scene so that he can
act and create a nice video.
But this also, like
Ellie mentioned before,
we should consider
the situation,
because this is an
asymmetric experience.
What you don't see
here is how frustrated
my son was after a
few minutes because he
couldn't see what was going on.
I was the one having fun
taking picture and video him,
and he didn't see much.
He could only hear
the lion roaring.
So we need to be
extremely mindful
as the developer about
this unbalance of delight.
And so maybe I should have
passed the image of the phone
to a nearby TV so I can make
my son first-class citizen
in this experience.
So all this AR technology
and the physical
and the visual understanding
are ingredients
that allow us to unlock all
kinds of new expressive input
mechanisms.
And we are still exploring.
We're just at the
beginning of this journey.
But we are excited to
hear what you think
and what you want
to come up with.
So to summarize,
we shared a bunch
of ways in which we think about
AR and various aspirations
that we have done.
We talked about expanding
our definition of AR.
Putting content into the world,
but also pulling information
from the world.
And these are all
ingredients that we
use to create these magical
AR superpowers to enhance
the social interactions
and to express yourself
in this new digital medium.
So we combined
ARCore capabilities
with different
Google technologies,
and this gives us
the opportunity
to explore all these
new interaction models.
And we encourage
you, developers,
to stretch your
definition of AR.
But we want to do this together.
We're going to keep
exploring, but what
we want to hear
what tickled you,
what tickled your curiosity.
So we can wait to see
what you build next.
Thank you very much for coming.
[MUSIC PLAYING]